on average flat roads like this cost
around $1 million per Lane mile to build
but these winding Mountain Roads can
cost up to 10 times that that's because
you can't just excavate rock you have to
blast and that's really expensive which
is one of the reasons why brand new
mountain roads aren't built very often
we only want to design and build them
once we asked a structural engineer with
over 25 years of experience to explain
how these Steep inclines and sharp turns
are designed to keep drivers safe in the
mountains there's a lot of different
kinds of mountain roads I think as a
tourist a lot of people think of the
very narrow windy mountain roads but
Additionally you have interstates going
through the mountains and those are
mountain roads hefron says that digging
a tunnel through the mountain is usually
expensive and highly risky so managing
that vertical climb is key that's what
we call the grade of the road and we
talk about it in percentages so for
every 100 fet you travel you want to try
to keep it to 5 ft Max in the mountains
a lot of times you're going to exceed
that you may go 6 and 1/2 or even 10%
Mountain Roads also have to maneuver
around a lot of natural obstacles
affecting its path or horizontal
alignment when you get to a mountain
setting the edges of your roadway are
defined by nature one of the things
you're trying to Define is how wide will
the roadway be we may decide to narrow
the lane widths up to 11 ft so that we
can stay out of the creek or not have to
blast into the adjacent Rock these
things are pretty imperceptible to the
driver you don't really get a tape
measure out every 100 ft but as a
designer you do when the terrain gets
too steep switchbacks become necessary
hefron says these tighter turns also
help reduce how much the mountain side
is affected by the road on a more rural
low volume Road you may have more switch
backs and Tighter turns it's a nice 200t
radius to make that switch back and get
around that curve whereas on an
interstate instead of 200 you have a
th000 about five times that when the
road curves there's usually an added
design feature called super elevation
which is where the roadway is tilted to
make it easier to navigate a curve so as
you're entering a curve as a driver and
you're turning the roadway isn't flat
but it's going to Super Elevate it's
going to raise on the high side kind of
like you see at a speed track the
centripetal force will keep you on the
roadway super elevation is especially
important in the mountains where roads
get icy quickly if the roadway were flat
especially if this roadway is icy you
could Veer off the roadway hefron says
super elevation starts at around 2% and
gets steeper as the speed of the roadway
increases sometimes in the mountains
you'll go 5 6% maybe 8 but you're you're
trying to keep it not too steep because
as this roadway ice is over and if
there's there's a lot of traffic during
a snowstorm and the cars go slower and
they might have the propensity to to
slide horizontally which is not safe
rockfall makes Mountain Road design even
more
challenging a lot of rock stability and
rockfall is controlled
specifically by the geometry this is
Howard Hume his job is to identify these
the brakes in the rock face also called
Rock joints and how they interact with
the face angle whether they project out
of the slope in which case they're a
problem in which case you've got to stop
them you can see horizontal jointing in
the face Hume says the stability of rock
faces varies widely but in general if
Rock joints are horizontal or at a very
low angle with respect to the road
that's not a problem if it's zipping
steeply and you're standing underneath
it that's definitely a problem human and
his team use a drone to take hundreds or
even thousands of photos of the rock
face got the area over there to create
models like this and this which she uses
to simulate different types of Rockall
this helps him decide the most stable
angle to cut the rock face when I say
cut eventually in rock like this you've
got to blast
it and then there's the surrounding
water that Engineers have to deal with
as the water is coming down from the
mountain sides it's moving fast to
manage this hefron says there are
various drainage systems like this or
this a lot of times you'll see it kind
of a pipe sticking out from the side of
the road and it comes out here and
drains away from the roadway into the
creek a lot of mountain roads started
out as Wagon Trails which generally
followed streams and Creeks this was
often the easiest and cheapest way to
get through the terrain over time those
Wagon Trails were adjusted and widened
to fit automobiles but being so close to
water means designers have to add
elements like rip wrap rip wrap is just
big rocks placed in a way such that it
helps stabilize and maintain the side of
the creek which is supporting the side
of your roadway water mitigation also
helps prevent soil erosion which can be
extremely dangerous for mountain
roads in 2020 a wildfire burned over
30,000 acres in Colorado's Glenwood
Canyon and because there was no
vegetation the storms that hit the area
the following year caused repeated
flooding and debris flow that shut down
a section of the interstate for about 2
weeks I70 is closed once again in
Glenwood Canyon this time for five
mudslides covering hundreds of feet a
highway even though Mountain Roads often
have more variables than flat roads
hefron says consistency is still the
goal we're going to have some steep
turns but if all of a sudden in our
design we interject along the roadway a
a very steep turn then your safety
overall goes down because of the lack of
consistency as people are traveling a
Mountain Road you don't want them to
think about the infrastructure you want
them to think about the beauty of the
nature that they're traveling through
you're getting the full experience it's
[Music]
snowing